thank you to expressvpn for sponsoring
this video citizens of the reject Nation
we have ourselves a trailer a trailer
for something that I honestly kind of
forgot was coming out reason being is
because you know nowadays you're always
hearing about the constant spinoffs and
things that are being put into
development from all these franchises
and IPS I usually just wait to see if
there's a trailer before I actually
believe it's coming out I've been so
focused on son the Hedgehog 3 that I
haven't even put much thought into the
knuckles spin-off series and I'm excited
that we are actually going to be getting
this show we're of course watching the
trailer for Knuckles thank you to all
who let me know the trailer was out it's
a Greg solo today couldn't get a hold of
my main co-host John but either way I'm
very much excited for this inevitably
excited too for the breakdown from 3C
films Chris who is an amazing guy has an
amazing YouTube channel I've learned so
much about Sonic via through him if you
guys are Sonic enthusiasts you guys
should really go watch his channel
anyway you guys know what to do leave a
like on this video be very much
appreciated also tell me in the comments
what is your favorite part about this
trailer who are you hoping shows up in
this series let's do
it you're an
alien you're super
powerful recently saved the world with
your friends yes what you
bad
Vengeance classic I think more like
reading or or
yoga
so you're going to be a Ser regular too
hey Buddy isn't it great to find oh
Sonic I am been a kid Warrior yeah you
arey I only remain on Earth because I
made a vow to you and the f I wonder how
is going to be here myself at
home nope we are not turning our living
room into some kind of gladiator
fighting pit what is Ali doing here he
will be challenging his greatest
enemy
it's a Negan is that our
mailman this is not a place of battle so
I will begin my quest oh he's got
the Hat think of a joke I do not make
jokes I make
warriors let's go get him so what's that
guy's name Wade is he without his little
friends he's
vulnerable he's the key to our my newest
creation is that the you for Robotnik
from Game of Thrones bring me
Knuckles oh sorry this Lane is
reserved you think you can take my
power like a bowling
ball do I look like I need your power
what are you talking about need power
it's the whole reason we're
here oh that's cool man they got the uh
they got the actual OVA hat
I made a promise to protect this
planet there's so many
images I
am ready oh slap sh someone's about to
get
slapped
fantastic whoa I think today is going to
be a beautiful
day that go down me you going to rescue
him no he must learn to rescue
himself there
go
Neo very neat oh man that looks really
good that looks like a really good time
I got some thoughts on that but before
going into that do want to thank today's
video sponsor big thanks to express VPN
for sponsoring this video a real game
changer I've been using for years that's
right years so whenever they want to
work with us it's an instant yes you've
likely heard about expressvpn for online
privacy and security but there's more to
it than that however there was a very
real incident recently with Spectrum
shutting down my internet and contacting
me due to a suspecting hacking attempt
and funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my Express VPN on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over a 100 countries like a global
Cinema your fingertips it's super easy
open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it
whether it's kramas on South Korean
Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube or
more expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows at anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com
rejects so head to expressvpn.com reex
to learn more thank you again you know
guys it is pretty crazy to see how far
we have come with the Sonic the Hedgehog
liveaction franchise because I still
remember like many of you when that
first trailer came out for Sonic the
Hedgehog and everyone was so upset by
the design that they went back and redid
the design and the movie came out people
really liked it sequel came out I I like
that one even more than the first one
Knuckles was the character that we were
all so excited for he was great in it
and this is a character that I do think
would make a really cool compelling lead
character to put it in a series format I
think is a really excellent call because
you know with him being the kid in a
warrior that's another thing that I
really like about this Knuckles is is
funny and I thought the movie really
captured that I remember in the
marketing for Sonic the Hedgehog 2 they
didn't even really lean so much into the
comedy of Knuckles that just lean to the
badassery of the guy and then you watch
the film and he is funny into my
understanding it's kind of like uh it's
kind of like how he is in the game you
can correct me if I'm wrong but my
recollection of of fan association with
the character in please do correct me if
I'm wrong he did start off a little bit
more you know like I said badass and
then as time went on they kind of just
lean more into the comedic element of
him throughout the games and what's cool
about this trailer is I feel like you're
going to get both you're not just going
to get the humor of Knuckles but you are
also going to get the true Aid a warrior
side of him with it being a show it also
allows more opportunity for more
character development more character
depth and uh while I I do like the
movies this show will just give it more
of an opportunity to really uh flesh him
out that much much more flush out the
world fles out the lore in a way that
you don't feel like you have to like
rush over to cuz you know like in in in
a movie you usually have like you got a
quot of things you you do got to hit you
got to have an action scene every you
know this certain amount of minutes or
or something along that line you guys
know how movies work but with a series
you get a little bit more time to
breathe and you I feel like you can get
more elements than just what you got
from the films while still giving you
the elements that you get from the films
like there's so much about this that
reminded me of the movies via through
the human characters instead of getting
you know James Marson Who sonic you know
pairs up with you're GNA get Knuckles
partner up with the Wade guy which I not
I remember I don't really remember how I
feel about wa I think he was all right
not like super excited about it he's not
the reason I'd be showing up for the
series but he does seem like he'd be the
main human protagonist alongside
Knuckles here where he'd be I guess
mentoring him in some way or showing him
the ways of the akid of warrior uh which
I feel like is a fun flip on on Dynamics
and what's really cool and and I still
am so wowed by this you know even though
we're we're in the day and age of like
the Golden Age of Television there's so
many streaming shows with just fantastic
visual effects that deserve to be seen
on the big screen I'm still of the
mindset a lot of the time that whenever
you do a spin-off into a TV series that
I feel my my natural hesitation is that
they're going to dumb down the visual
effects in some way or it's going to
feel lesser than looking at this trailer
the effects and the quality are still up
to the standards of watching a Sonic the
Hedgehog movie and speaking of Sonic the
Hedgehog I imagine it probably just
being like the first episode you know
just to to get that out of the way
that's usually what you got to do is you
instead of like building up and
wondering when Sonic's going to come and
you just kind of like feed that appetite
right away so you're not thinking about
it the rest of the show that being said
I don't know who else is going to show
up in the series I like how they just
kept it pretty focused on Knuckles the
journey there and uh the Hound I don't
know the actor's name that didn't get CC
what is that guy's name but the I'm just
going to pull up IMDb really quick Rory
mccan my God there's a whole bunch of
actors in This Carrie Elis is going to
appear Christopher Lloyd's gonna be in
here kid Cy Eddie Patterson my God you
see you do see Paul Shear in the trailer
okay so there's no Jim Carrey listed
here but he is confirmed to return for
Sonic 3 and I I don't know if how much
this is going to tie into Sonic 3 like
is this going to be
necessary viewing are they going to
build out the Cinematic Universe of
Sonic the Hedgehog to that degree where
I I watch Sonic 3 and if I didn't watch
the series am I going to feel like left
out or are they going to do that Marvel
thing where they recap just like a
couple of sentences that are required
for me to understand the Journey of
Knuckles returning are they going to set
up shadow in some way in this series
just slowing down this trailer I'm
loving the designs of all the meca suits
and then I'm trying to find this one
character here here that it popped up
for a brief SEC who is this guy can you
guys tell me in the comments below is
this supposed to be like knuckles's Dad
or something cuz it kind of looks like
it looks like they could be related and
I guess the last thing is you know one
thing with with characters um you know
you got tals here and then you know at
the end of Sonic the Hedgehog to you see
the evolution of Sonic's powers and I'm
wondering how much of an evolution we
going to get and and knuckles's powers
or if we'll we'll see an evolution and
power set you know you got tales in the
trailer as well if we'll see an
evolution there like what are the
upgrades going to be ultimately what
will the the character Arc be for the
guy because you know Knuckles does have
a character Arc in the in the second
movie so I'm wondering what the specific
journey is cuz they it feels like really
like clearly defined for Sonic in the in
the first two movies while I I'm looking
forward to the uh potential for better
exploration for this character at the
same time I am going all right what is
going to be the specific Journey this
guy's going to be be going on and I mean
I just watched the trailer one time I
should just watch it again and maybe
I'll be like I know what that answer is
but you guys tell me in the comments you
guys are smarter than me leave it in the
comments Below guys what did you think
about this trailer I thought it was more
than satisfactory it's a pretty cool
trailer man it's pretty sweet leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
uh leave a like uh we got more trailers
I'm sure to cover coming out of Super
Bowl talk to youall
[Music]
soon